amelia sarantopoulos i'm a machine
learning engineer at beat
and today we'll be discussing about
real-time
machine learning services and how they
would go from ideation
uh all the way to production so first of
all a few things about beat
so beat is uh the fastest growing
ride-hailing app in latin america
it connects passengers with nearby
available drivers
in real time and all these of course
operates on a
24 7 basis so it provides fast safe
reliable and affordable transportation
and it operates in peru chile colombia
mexico and argentina
it's part of the free now group which is
the right healing joint venture of
bmw and daimler so
since we're talking about an application
here it would be important to
you know get a sense of you know what is
a typical operation
uh a use of the app as we would use it
on a mobile phone
so the user would input their location
they would request
where they would like to go and then
they would pick one of the available
options that would be
uh you know one of the available
services that exists like
light uh a beat core and loxi
and then they would uh request uh to
give a ride
and a driver would be dispatched for
them so what is important here to
note is that you know b is operating on
a two-sided marketplace
so one on one side you have the
passengers and
on the other side you have uh
drivers so the passenger
needs to get a ride so we must decide
what is the important price uh what is
the exact price for this uh
ride and also the driver uh we need to
decide on who will be dispatched for
this ride
so now let's jump into something into
more specifics
um so we're gonna introduce you to kathy
so who's kathy kathy is a machine
learning engineer
data scientist slash ai unicorn so she
has all these skills that somebody
uh would like for an employee of this
type to have
so basically she has
a really good background in probability
and statistics
she has a deep understanding of machine
learning algorithms and methods
and she also has you know during the
last couple of years experienced
training and debugging deep learning
models and if you couple all that with
her
software engineering skills and her
acquaintance with
data engineering tools um
and also her devops skills you know
you've got basically
uh the whole cross-functional skill set
that
a development team should have of course
when we refer to kathy
uh it can be one person it can be
multiple person
it can be the whole uh a whole team
you know with all these uh diverse uh
with all this diverse skill set so
she was described with a problem with a
problem
so in an ideal world um in this typical
scenario we would have demand and supply
they will be balanced but of course as
not everything is ideal uh
in reality we would experience these uh
these types of cases so if we think
about this here as a
an image of the city uh we would
uh experience at times that you know
a bunch of people would be uh gathered
in one place and they would
would like to get a ride and
a bunch of drivers would be in another
place so
all of this of course uh is something
that
happens and will always happen because
you know the cities are dynamic
and you can have like uh certain events
happening like uh
maybe there is a sudden road closure or
there is a strike or even a concert that
finished earlier or later as
from scheduled so in order to balance
this
[Music]
b imposes dynamic pricing which would be
an increase over the price
in order to provide motive to the
drivers
to go into that place and in that way
tweaking supply
let's say and also
this way you create a better app
experience because at the end of the day
you know people use apps because they're
useful for something
if someone opened up the app and they
couldn't get a ride when they tried five
or ten times
of course the eleventh time they
wouldn't even try uh so
to to get these rules uh always when we
think about machine learning solutions
we
start from some legacy way of doing
things so
maybe a legacy way would be to have
handcrafted manual rules
uh for its specific time
timestamp and for each specific part of
the city
and of course that's too much of a
burden but instead of being reactive
in this way we can be proactive so
kathy thought about this with her team
and they
said that okay we can provide a solution
which
would involve a first step to with
that would include the time series
prediction so
predicting certain kpis
given historic data
so all of this starts with this is the
first version
of the solution that they came up with
so first of all it starts with data
availability
so we have two data engineering jobs
uh they created so one would be a
training job
a batch job basically that would be used
for the training
data and a streaming job that would be
used for serving
uh slash inference so
the the training job i
would just would aggregate all these raw
events
uh as they would leave into some
production data source they would
aggregate it in
specified uh pre-specified time
intervals let's say
10 minutes five minutes whatever the
the need is um and then it would
do some uh aggregations uh over these
raw events
and provide uh something
[Music]
an end result something like this here
so for a specific time interval we
would have these values for feature one
and these values for future two
and it goes on and on and of course
because this needs to be
a real-time service or let's
you know be more precise and near real
time
service we also created the streaming
job
which would read data uh with it
it would consume data from kafka as they
would come in and create the exact same
data set
so uh in order to uh
transform this into a supervised
learning problem um
one needs to uh do several kind of
transformations but the most important
thing is that
you need to create your targets and your
inputs
your input variables so out of this
source
for example if we want to be one step
proactive
and predict uh the next
time step we will create these samples
like given
time step t and these two features
uh we would our target will consist
of these two values for time step t
plus four times time t plus one and the
same for t
plus one and t plus two of course you
can be as proactive as you want
and like uh
given time step t predict
t plus one and
apart from this transformation of course
uh when solving problems with time
series
we would have also splitting the data
set
perform scaling transform the time
series to a stationary one
and so on so at the end
we would have all these features here
um as we said they're gonna be some
internal features
uh rides a number of rides that happened
number of people that requested a ride a
number of available drivers
uh and these would be uh let's see
aggregated on uh
on a specific time stamp for a specific
part of the city
and we can also include uh
some demographics and information about
this particular zone of the city and
also we can add third-party features
like weather
uh events that may be happening uh
throughout
town uh like as we mentioned concerts uh
festivals
um information about you know specific
holidays
uh and all of these then they will go
into this box where the ammo
magic happens uh so
of course there's no magic over here but
we just you know
uh we're just hitting it under the hood
so over here
um anyone can employ uh
whichever uh framework uh he or she
wants
so kathy here use tensorflow but of
course uh
uh pytorch cellular next boost light gbm
and uh you name it uh whatever can be
used
and the output of this would be as we
said the requested kpis
into uh
one step further in time
so when we think about machine learning
workflows
uh you know we inherently think about
pipelines
and that makes sense because after all
they're just pipelines
uh but the thing is that if you compared
with
a more let's say traditional software
engineering task it's not
that linear at all so you would collect
data
you would do model training and
deployment but you would have to do
these things
over and over again so you create a data
set you do model training
and then when you evaluate it you go on
you
try out some new features maybe a new
model
and then when you have something
reasonable reasonable enough you deploy
it into production
and then starts the other circular uh
way of doing things that from deployment
you want to get an even better solution
so uh this simple thing here
usually when we break it down uh when
people break it down to
uh tasks uh it ends up being you know
something monstrous
like this one so you would do
a whole bunch of stuff you would do data
fetching you would clean the data
then perform some transformations uh
validate this data set build a model
tune it and so on so
uh and it can happen you can have many
many more steps
uh if you zoom as you zoom in
uh more into the application so
kathy did all this with his team and
what would be
reasonable enough that you know the next
step would be to go into production
but this didn't happen and of course she
was devastated
and this is a really common thing that
many of these these types of solutions
never reach production and this can
happen for uh
many reasons uh some shallow other deep
uh but kathy and her team narrowed it
down to
some to some specifics when it comes to
training models mostly
so the first most important thing is
reproducibility
so whenever we perform experiments
you know a really important thing for
people in order to be reliable is
reproducibility
so maybe you needed to
retrain a model because of some major
update or upgrade in the package that
you're using let's say tensorflow
and you want to be you want to have your
code up to date
so you tried this and you didn't get the
same results
and this can happen for uh you know a
specific set of reasons
uh a really common thing would be you
know
you get data from one source uh like a
database an hdfs cluster um
and then you train the model but what if
uh data in the data source have changed
for some reason maybe there was
uh you know something wrong with uh the
data
over there in the beginning and someone
went in fixed it
and performed the backfill so the second
thing
has to do with what we what we know as
concept or model drift so
the data change over time and that means
that you have to do
the data distribution change basically
so you need to do retrain
uh every once in a while if you do this
manually of course it's a really big
burden
and if you couple this with uh deploying
rarely
so then you can have many features
uh piled up and a model that
doesn't have you know that good
performance
so one of the last things is that
you know what did cathy do so she took a
problem
uh so she got her input and then behind
closed doors with her team
they came up with a solution and they
then provided you know a ready product
so uh throughout
but having no feedback throughout the
development process
so miscommunic this can lead to
miscommunication
so it's really important to have
feedback with uh
and not only within the team but also
with stakeholders
throughout this process and all of these
up uh
if you pile them up together they end up
having a decreased velocity
in you know adding value to the final
product
so then what did they do
so they sat down and they came up with
a specific set of options
uh to explore to give a second version
to the solution
uh so first of all uh
they adopted things from the software
engineering
world so for example continuous
integration
um if you're working in a distributed
team it's really good to be
a coherent in terms of code style and
do some static analysis um
in that case you can you know leave
these things out and focus on the things
that matter you know
like significant code changes also you
you need to run unit tests and check for
test coverage
in an isolated environment like a docker
image and
also do some checks in your software
packages
and also sell checks for some bus strips
that may appear in your repo
so the second thing uh
we talked about we mentioned
reproducibility so
we all version uh code like with some
version control system like kit
mostly uh why not do the same with
data so
[Music]
when we're talking about you know
applications we want to have a rollback
functionality
and that means that you know
reproducibility should be an option
uh and the same goes for um
you know so this you can divide it into
models and data
uh so we can solve the model thing by
you know applying random seeds into
our into our frameworks whenever there
is some uh
random factor there but you know we
can't
we haven't solved uh the problem with
data so
you can do data versioning so kathy here
use the dvc which is data version
control but of course you can use
other types of tools like pachyderm
which do pretty much a similar job and
what you do is that you can keep track
of data sets and models so of course we
have you know
specific uh release
indeed goes hand in hand with a specific
model performance and this model
performance has
originated from a specific data set so
all of these
need to be version you know you have you
need to have end-to-end versioning
so with dvc you can keep
a signature of the data set along with
your code which would be a hash value
of your data set and then this will be
you know the link where this will
communicate
with a dvc repository with which is
pretty much uh a git
gita like uh repo so you can
pull and push the data from a remote
source
into your uh local machine so
we discussed about reproducibility but
now we also have the problem of
manual training
so every once in a while we would like
to perform
a hyper parameter tuning and this could
happen
you know on two occasions one would be
this would be a triggered event
uh so you can have either a new release
from your version control system was
push the master so you will need to if
you have changes in your models you want
to
perform uh retraining or if you have new
features
another thing could be again in this
triggered scenario
that you're monitoring your real life
performance
of your model so if you experience that
for a certain amount of time the
performance has degraded you need to
trigger you know
a new training cycle a second
occasion would be that you can have a
repeating uh something like a crown job
uh running on a scheduled basis like
every
day every week every month uh whatever
the application
uh needs and then uh this would
run a training at scale let's call it
and
here only you know hyperparameter tuning
is distinguished for
from training only in the scenario that
you do
hyper parameter tuning on the subset of
your data
because it's you know it's so enormous
that you cannot it would not
finish in an efficient amount of time
uh and then uh and dashed
here uh arrow this would be deployed
only and
only if it gets if it gives a better
uh performance so when we jump
into continuous delivery uh to the
second part
uh so kathy and her team
they used uh keep flow so
everyone everyone uses you know tools
or a lot of people have created some
tools
for their own use trying to orchestrate
these
ml workflows um of course there are
other tools that you can use
but uh since they use kubeflow we're
going to talk about this one
so what it basically does it's it's
an end-to-end pipeline orchestration so
you can have easy experimentation and
you can have some reusable components in
the pipeline which you can then take
them
and use them in to another problem and
of course you can
organize your experiments
in a hierarchical way and
all of this is done on top of
kubernetes so giving you all the
advantages
scaling up and down when needed um
and basically having a one place for
your whole
uh pipeline like you can have model
we can you can have the artifacts in
cube flow like models and metrics
and all the other stuff so
from this um kubeflow has also
a really nice another tool called catib
so catib does hyper parameter tuning
which is
a really demanding task both in terms of
time
as well as resources so
it is used to parallelize training runs
in separate pods
it records metrics and then it will give
the best model
and the really important thing here uh
is that okay apart from the ui
uh it's basically a framework agnostic
tool
so you know it doesn't really
uh it has no idea you know what's
running
underneath so all you need is uh a
docker image that will take some
hyper parameters as input like learning
rate number of layers
uh the optimizer etc and
it will just post some metrics on the
standard output
and then you can decide you know which
of this metric
which of these metrics will be minimized
uh or
maximized it will just read that
this from standard output and it will
give you uh
you know the best model um
and of course uh this
because it's done on kubernetes again it
you know it makes it really easy
to just scale up
and run let's say uh dozens of
experiments in parallel
if we're talking about random search or
grid certs and
you know achieve your results much
faster
so the last thing that we discussed is
continuous feedback
so this goes two ways the first way is
about
continuous feedback you know from uh the
developers from people
towards the application and the models
so
one thing would have to do with of
course monitoring the application
so over there you need to always check
you know that everything's running on
time
and that you're writing in the
appropriate data sources
um and that everything is function
like functioning smoothly so
you can use tools like graffana for that
uh
and the second thing is that you need to
monitor model performance
so when you have a real-time
applications you know uh
if things go south for some reason you
need to know as soon as fast
so uh you can monitor performance
training performance with things like
tensorboard and then you can have
uh tools like grafana or
other stuff to to monitor uh
things in real time and perhaps set
alerts for example as we mentioned
previously
uh for the uh for triggering a new
uh a new training run uh so you can
check you know
what happens and for example here it may
or may not be significant enough to
issue a new training
and last but not least uh
we we talked about continuous feedback
towards uh you know the application but
we also
need to communicate with people so
throughout the life cycle of the project
kathy tried certain ways to
communicate with the stakeholders so the
first one would be reports
but then it didn't really work out
because reports were you know they're
not dynamic so what we want when we're
dealing with data
we want to have something we want to
have dynamic feedback so
reports you build it you send it and
after you know
one or two hours it's already stale
and the same thing happens with slides
and
i really another thing is that you know
reports of slides
they're not reproducible and they're
static
and they're too time consuming for
people to create
so another option would be jupiter
notebooks but when you're dealing with
non-technical audiences you can just
give them you know an ipi and b
um file uh
and the second you give them uh you know
an html file you would have
or a pdf you you again have the same
problem with reports
only you have some code in it with make
which makes it a mess so this was not an
option
again so what they found out was that
you can use
data apps so we all love web apps
they're really
dynamic people know how to build them so
one example is streamlead which is
makes uh building data apps really
really fast
so you can use this both ways you can
use it for the development team as well
as
potential stakeholders to be able to
check
what is happening and that way you know
you have
you gain more visibility across your
organization
and you can be more reliable as well
so to sum up we talked about how we can
solve reproducibility
with data version control um
concept drift and rare deployments by
using
uh end-to-end pipeline orchestration and
feedback
by using web apps and all of these they
sum up
and give an increase into the overall
team's velocity
uh when delivering so
if you haven't checked out these
resources please they're amazing so
these people here that have uh gathered
everything
over the last couple of years that
people have been you know having really
trouble
uh dealing with and they put it in one
place so
that was all thank you very much for
listening uh
do we have any questions yes we do
thanks for the awesome talk yeah um
i really liked it and i'm sure the
audience likes it a lot as well
um we have a lot of questions but with
respect to time we'll only take a few
one of the common questions we received
is what we
i'll just sum it up so what do you use
for tracking hyper parameters across
your experiments there was questions
about
ml flow and if you guys are using that i
saw you're using cube flow so that also
has a built-in module katib
so what's your take on this exactly
uh so my take or kathy's take
that is taken so kathy used the
tip because it's uh um
you know it's it's kubernetes native so
uh as things have moved to the cloud uh
they just use this tool uh in order to
have basically you know
uh a united stack so not use uh you know
uh different tools here and there uh so
it offers really good tracking like you
can get you know when you have some
experiments running you can get you know
the results for these that have been
running you can get
the best result out of these and when
the experiment finishes
you get the best out of everything uh so
of course as i said you know you can use
dvc
uh pachyderm uh mlflow
instead of uh cube flow so they're all
just tools you just need to
to figure out what you want to do and
then
you just select you know your tools
yeah just basically be aware of the
challenges of operationalizing ml model
and use a tool to deal with that and
another good questions we received
is what if you have anything to test
your model any framework or any tool for
that
okay so kathy used uh
you know just basic unit testing so
when you're dealing with uh so let's say
when you're using tensorflow
uh there some specific stuff that you
can check so of course you're not going
to uni test
uh you know the application itself
you're not going to
uh unit test the internals of tensorflow
that would be an overkill
uh but you can check that when you build
the model
that you're using the uh
the layers that you have built uh are
being actually used
uh and another thing would be that
you could test um
that uh you don't have
let's say zero uh losses
or especially try to explore things that
can be fishy
when training right yes perfect we have
more questions but i really encourage
them to go then on discord and
if you have some time maybe engage with
our audiences on discord
okay if you want to solve problems like
this uh
feel free to check our careers page for
machine learning engineer data
scientists and data analyst positions
so thank you very much everyone thank
you